انتشر مقطع فيديو اثار غضب العراقيين لاحد
شيوخ العشائر وهو يواجه اتهاما مباشره
لقائد عمليات محافظه ديالى اللواء الركن
علي عمران بعرض رشوه عليه بقيمه 500,000
دولار لغرض اسكاته عن حقائق معينه وبعد
دجه واسعه احدثها هذا الفيديو امرت وزاره
الدفاع بفتح تحقيق الفوري لكشف حقيقه ما
حدث ما حدث وسائل الاعلام محليه ذكرت ان
المشاهد تم تصويرها داخل مجلس عزاء بمنطق
دياله
وان شاء الله الثانيه نقلت بسببها انت
وجيت دزيت وساطه عليه قلبت الدنيا حتى
وصلت الى 50
خلال الساعات الماضيه بعد ما انتشرت صور
مركبات قيل انها مخباه في مزرعه مهجوره في
مدينه الكارثه التركيه واضافت التعليقات
المرفقه للصور المنتشره ان تلك السيارات
الفاخره تعود لقياده في الحكومه السودانيه
السابقه وذلك في وقت تعمل فيه السلطات
السودانيه على مصادره الشركات وعقارات
وممتلكات تعود الى عهد النظام السابق
ومساعده تقدره قيمتها بمليارات الدولارات
لكن تبين لاحقا انها مجرد تصاميم رقميه
نشرها فنان ايطالي في حسابه على انستغرام
تم القاء القبض على سيدتين بمطارخ
كولومبيا بعدما كشفت اجهزه الامن العثور
على كوكايين في وصلات شعرهما عندما كان
تاء في طريقهما لرحله متجهه الى مدريد
فيديو اثار الرعب على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعيه عاده للاذهان بدايات ازمه
كورونا صاحبه الفيديو مدونه الاكل الشهيره
التايلنديه
ظهرت فيه وهي تاكل خفاشا قائله انه وجبه
لذيذه السلطات التايلانديه القت القبض على
صاحبه الفيديو واتهامتها بمخالفه القوانين
الصحيه واكلها حيوانا يمنع صيده في ما
تواجه المدونه عقوبه بالسجن مدتها خمس
سنوات
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء